sí buenas noches de la cala
efectivamente en el tercer día de
movilizaciones indígenas el día de hoy
el ejecutivo nacional tanto la
confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas se ha pronunciado en torno a
lo que ha sido en balance de las
movilizaciones en principio el ejecutivo
nacional ya ha expresado preocupación
por el creciente el tipo de violencia
que poco a poco se ha venido
incrementando el día de hoy se han
venido bloqueando los accesos de ingreso
por la parte sur de la ciudad y de igual
forma también los comuneros que empiezan
a llegar a la ciudad capital ingresaron
en camiones ingresaron caminando
recorrieron la ciudad capital y salieron
de la ciudad capital también empieza a
verse ciertas concentraciones que van
incrementándose en el característico
parque del arbolito una zona de
concentraciones muy características de
protestas en esta ciudad de igual forma
también el ejecutivo nacional ha
minimizado también lo que ha sido la
fuerza de la protesta ha dicho que tan
solo sé
contabilizan 5000 personas que estarían
protestando en el país no así los
movimientos indígenas han emitido un
pronunciamiento y básicamente leonidas
iza ha llamado a ratificar la protesta y
usted precisamente menciona a leonidas
iza el presidente de la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas y quien fue
arrestado el martes ahora está en
libertad condicional pero su arresto
tuvo muchas irregularidades e hizo que
los indígenas llamaran a protestas más
fuertes cuéntanos qué está pasando en
este caso
si tal y como tras la captura de
leonidas iza ha estado muy cuestionada
desde el inicio de su aprensión en la
madrugada del día martes tanto el
ejecutivo nacional como la confederación
de nacionalidades indígenas ha
cuestionado la forma como fue apresado
en principio la unidosis a aseguraba que
él no estaba cometiendo ningún tipo de
delito de flagrancia tal y como se lee e
intenta procesar ha dicho la jueza del
caso que se espera que será procesado en
libertad pero por el delito de bloqueo
de vías públicas para sin embargo el
ejecutivo en nacional sí asegura que
estaba cometiendo un delito en este
sentido también leonidas iza asegura que
no se les leyeron los derechos para sin
embargo el ejecutivo nacional si lo
justifica y ha dicho que posteriormente
mostró un vídeo donde se le leía sus
derechos en un lugar diferente donde fue
capturado lo cierto es que el día de hoy
es ratifica mantener en la protesta
hasta conseguir una respuesta por parte
del ejecutivo nacional